[APPLAUSE]
KUNAL: It's a dark--
just so you know,
Jesse Eisenberg wrote
a beautiful play.
We're going to show
you-- in the beginnings,
it's a scene from the
beginning, pretty much,
right when the play starts.
We play roommates.
This is Ben's apartment.
He is an aspiring filmmaker.
I'm getting my MBA at NYU
Stern School of Business.
And I'm from Nepal.
And then, we just begin acting.
Cool.
JESSE: OK.
KUNAL: More nervous to do
this now than on stage.
JESSE: Yeah.
KALYAN: Hey, oh, hey, Ben,
did you film anything today?
BEN: Nothing needed
to be filmed.
KALYAN: Mm, I saw this thing
I think you might have liked.
I know how you are
always trying to capture
real and dramatic
moments for your film.
BEN: Compelling.
Not dramatic,
there's a difference.
KALYAN: Yeah, OK.
Sorry, compelling.
I saw this compelling
situation I
think you might have liked, OK.
So, there's a man eating
food out of a garbage bag
that he had clearly
torn open himself.
And then a dog
ran up and started
eating out of the same bag.
And the guy didn't mind.
Like they were eating the same
food-- the man and the dog.
It was so strange
and disgusting,
but it was also
peaceful, in a way, made
me feel like we can
just all coexist, even
in this gruesome way.
BEN: All right,
wrap it up, buddy.
Long story short.
KALYAN: Yeah, OK.
Sorry, I'm just--
I'm getting to it.
So this rich looking-woman
approaches, right?
And she grabs the dog
away by the collar,
and yells at it for eating
the food from the garbage.
She says something like,
she says, oh yeah, she says,
Baxter, no.
We don't eat food
from the garbage.
She said, we.
Like Baxter, the dog, and she
eat the same kind of food.
But the food from the
garbage was good enough
for the homeless man.
I just thought it was so sad to
see how human beings can value
animals over another person,
like another stranger who
happens to be a human being.
And I just it might be really
interesting for your film.
BEN: Yeah, all due respect, man.
It's not really
that interesting.
I mean, I see shit
like that all the time.
And it's kind of cliche to
show like a sad, homeless dude
eating garbage.
KALYAN: Yeah, it's probably
not the most original thing
in the world--
BEN: It's probably the most
un-original thing in the world.
And that's the fucking problem
with these NYU assholes.
You know, it's like they take
a picture of a homeless guy
and they call it, art.
It's like, fuck you.
That's not art.
Might be art if
you were homeless,
but then you wouldn't be at
fucking NYU now would you.
KALYAN: Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
BEN: Yeah, and I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to put that NYU, I
know you're still happy there.
KALYAN: Well, they
didn't kick me out.
BEN: Yeah, well, you're in the
business school, my friend.
It's a much different
pile of shit.
OK, and they didn't
kick me out either.
We had a mutual falling out.
KALYAN: I know you did.
BEN: OK, and the
graduate department
can suck my shit, because
they didn't know what they
had on their hands with me.
All right, they didn't know what
to think of me, all right, what
fucking little box to put me in.
Well guess what?
KALYAN: What?
I know what.
BEN: When my movie comes out, I
will get an honorary Ph.D. OK,
a fucking Ph.D. And don't
think I won't accept it,
because I will accept it.
Yes, yes, I'll
fucking accept it.
And I'll even make
a classy speech
and I'll even say, thank
you, and even shake hands
with those fuck wads.
Because if there's
one thing I've
learned from my struggling,
it's that the best revenge
is a life well lived.
KALYAN: That's very sage.
BEN: Thanks, man.
You want some weed?
KALYAN: No.
BEN: I'm going to smoke
some, nonetheless.
KALYAN: OK.
BEN: Yo.
KALYAN: Mm?
BEN: I had a shitty day, Bunty.
I mean, I mean shitty
compared to my other days,
not compared to world
events or anything.
KALYAN: What happened?
BEN: So I'm crossing Third
Avenue, and I run into this kid
that I went to elementary
school with, Ted.
He said he's getting married.
What a douche bag, right?
[SNICKERS]
KALYAN: I don't know, is he?
All I know is that
he's named Ted
and that he's getting married.
BEN: Yeah, so he says
to me, he says to me,
can you believe I'm
actually getting married.
He says, can you believe
I'm finally settling down.
So I said, yes I can.
You're a boring Jew-y
douche bag from New Jersey
who never had a girlfriend.
Of course, I can
you're settling down.
What the fuck else
are you going to do?
Mow someone's lawn?
KALYAN: I hope you
actually didn't say that.
BEN: No, no, I said,
congratulations.
Yeah, but I was thinking
that pretty loud and clear.
So, message received.
Yeah.
Anyway, Ted got a job
working on Wall Street.
He's some kind of hotshot
fuck or something.
KALYAN: Hey really?
Did you ask him, which firm?
BEN: Yeah, I asked him
for his whole life story.
We were crossing
the street, Kalyan.
I didn't get into all that shit.
KALYAN: Well, did you ask him
if there was a job opening?
BEN: You don't want to
work on Wall Street.
KALYAN: No Ben, that's
exactly where I want to work.
Why else you think I'm here?
BEN: What.
You're here to learn, OK.
You're here to learn.
And I told you, you
don't need a job.
I don't want rent from you.
Your money's no good here.
KALYAN: I don't
want to rely on you.
I want to pay you rent.
BEN: Fine, then.
I'll ask him if
there's a fucking job.
Man, get off my jock.
He gave me his number.
KALYAN: Fine, if it's a
problem, just let me know.
BEN: No, no, he actually
said-- he actually wanted
to hang out with us, he did.
He said, we should get
together for drinks.
Yeah, dude.
KALYAN: What?
BEN: Come on, what kind of
bourgeois bullshit is that?
Get together for drinks.
Come on, you never hear
someone in the Democratic
Republican of the
fucking Congo say,
let's get together for drinks.
KALYAN: Especially
because there's a drought.
BEN: Nah, that's
actually funny man.
You know, your sense
of humor is burgeoning.
KALYAN: Thanks, I
learned from the best.
BEN: I'm the best.
Anyway.
You want to hear the
fucking kicker of it all.
The real salt in the wound
of this whole thing--
guess who this guy is marrying.
Sarah Newburgh.
KALYAN: I don't
know who that is.
BEN: What?
She's the first girl I
ever got an erection for,
Sarah fucking Newburgh.
KALYAN: Really, like
your first crush, huh.
BEN: Yeah, yeah, and
it pisses me off.
Ah, if I'm being honest, Bunty,
it really does piss me off.
KALYAN: I know it does, buddy.
BEN: Man, the world is not fair.
Well, you know that.
You're from Nepal.
But-- but it's unfair
here too, sometimes.
I just feel like everything
is so fucked, sometimes.
Sarah was like-- Sarah
was really nice to me.
KALYAN: It's going
to be OK, man.
BEN: What?
KALYAN: It's going to be OK.
BEN: Yeah, I-- what?
I know that.
Dude, I fucking
know-- I know that.
KALYAN: OK.
BEN: Dude, anyway,
she's probably like ugly
as shit, by now.
She probably turned into her
mother, all hips, no ass,
but she was cute,
if I'm being honest.
KALYAN: Hey, are
you jealous of Ted?
BEN: Jealous?
KALYAN: Yeah, it's
OK if you are.
I'm jsut--
BEN: Fuck no.
He's an idiot.
He's a fucking banker.
I'm actually doing
something with my life.
OK, and I don't have time
for some bitch in my ear,
anyway, taking me
away from my work.
KALYAN: Yeah, you're
going to do great things.
BEN: Oh, come on.
Dude, come one.
I'm not saying all
bankers are idiots.
He's a fucking Jewish
banker from New Jersey.
All right, he's a
fucking Shylock,
perpetuating stereotypes
that, frankly, I
don't need right now.
It's different than
you being in finance.
KALYAN: How is it different
than me being in finance?
BEN: Look, it's kind
of hard to describe,
because you're not from here.
OK, but, if you're born in
the states, and you're white,
and you're (WHISPERING)
fucking Jewish,
and you're middle class, banking
is seen as an easy way out.
It doesn't have the
nobility that you think.
KALYAN: Wait, I don't think
it's necessarily noble, Ben.
I wouldn't call it noble.
I don't think its any more or
less noble than any other job.
I found it interesting,
and I think it's a good way
to make a living.
BEN: OK, fine.
But for a Jewish kid
from the suburbs,
and I'm fucking speaking as a
Jewish kid from the suburbs,
it's not interesting.
And it's a shitty
way to make a living.
OK, look it's like if
I-- hey, it's like,
if I was born in
Nepal, like you,
OK, and I wanted to be
a Sherpa, or a Gurkha,
or a parka, or whatever,
that would be like-- that
would be an easy way out.
KALYAN: Gurkhas are considered
the preeminent fighting squad
in the world.
BEN: I'm sure they're great.
KALYAN: Sherpas can summit
Everest without oxygen.
BEN: Fine.
KALYAN: Parkas keep you
insulated from a cold breeze.
BEN: Uh-huh.
That's very cute.
OK, that's very-- you're funny.
OK, but what I'm
trying to say is
that-- I'm trying to
basically not insult you--
is the fact that you're
from a fucking poor country,
I'm sorry, a poor country,
and you've come to the states
to study business is
admirable, in a way that,
for a fucking Jew, sorry,
for a Jew from the suburbs
is predictable.
KALYAN: What about movies?
BEN: What the fuck about movies?
KALYAN: You want to make
movies, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
You do make movies, right.
Isn't the movie industry
disproportionately Jewish?
BEN: Yes, and I have
two answers for you
that I've already thought of,
because I think about this shit
all the time.
OK.
One is that I'm not
going to be some fucking
rich-casting-couch-like
film executive, OK.
And the other is
that arts and cinema
can reflect life and
push boundaries in ways
that moving money around
to make more of it
will simply never
be able to, OK?
And I was getting a
degree in film theory.
I'll be making fucking pittance
and I'm perfectly OK with that.
KALYAN: And you could always
borrow money from your father.
BEN: You want a hit?
KALYAN: Is it still marijuana?
BEN: Yeah.
KALYAN: No.
BEN: My father is a prick, ok?
Hey, Bunty--
KALYAN: Yeah.
BEN: Yo, Bunty, can
I tell you a secret?
KALYAN: Yeah, of course, please.
BEN: OK.
Wait, have I offended you
with the banking comments?
No, because if I've
offended you, I'm sorry.
But I'm also frankly
uncomfortable moving forward,
if I've offended you.
KALYAN: I'm not offended.
BEN: OK, because I
couldn't live with myself.
I would actually-- I'd fucking
kill myself, in some way,
if I've offended you.
And I can't keep
moving forward thinking
I've hit an animal in the road.
No, I can't keep driving
forward thinking there's
a dead animal behind me--
KALYAN: There's no dead animal.
BEN: Because I think you're
a fucking awesome person.
OK, and the fact that
you are like from Nepal
and you're studying
business at NYU,
whatever, makes you an awesome
friend and an awesome roommate.
And I am proud as shit
that we know each other.
KALYAN: I'm also proud
of this relationship.
BEN: Yeah?
You know you're a
stand-up guy, Bunty.
KALYAN: Thanks.
BEN: All right,
here's my secret.
KALYAN: OK.
BEN: Thank you.
OK so, when I was
eight years old,
I had a dream about Sarah
Newburgh, this fuck face's
new fiance.
KALYAN: Wait, like a sex dream.
BEN: It was more
than a sex dream.
It was um-- hey, is
it cool if I tell you
something kind of disgusting.
KALYAN: I think so.
BEN: Are you easily nauseated?
KALYAN: Uh, in Kathmandu, I
had giardia for four months,
so I have a pretty
strong stomach.
BEN: Dude, I'm sorry to
hear about your giardia.
KALYAN: It's OK,
It's all cleared up.
BEN: Yeah?
KALYAN: Yeah.
BEN: All right.
So when I was eight
years old, I had a dream
that I was lying on the floor
of my second grade classroom.
I had pushed the desks
against the wall.
And I had spread newspaper
neatly all over the floor.
And I was lying
on the newspaper.
I was face up and naked.
And-- now here's
the disgusting part,
I'm kind of
embarrassed to say it.
KALYAN: Go ahead, please.
BEN: Yeah?
KALYAN: Yeah, yeah, of course.
BEN: Ok, so Sarah Newburgh
the uh-- well, the presumably
respectable fiance of the
douche bag I just ran into,
was actually standing over me.
She was straddling my face.
She was also naked and well
she was shitting on me.
KALYAN: She was
defecating on you?
BEN: Yeah, on my
face, on my face.
Yeah.
I've got to feel fucking
awful about this.
I'm so mortified.
Oh my god, I've never
told anyone this before.
Do you know what it's like to
go through life with this image
stuck in your dumb head--
a naked eight-year-old
girl shitting on your face.
Oh god, hey Bunty, am I awful?
KALYAN: Let me
think for a moment.
BEN: Yeah, yeah.
Take your time buddy.
KALYAN: OK.
Yeah, I mean, I
think if you-- OK,
I think if you had the dream
now and Sarah was still
the 8-year-old girl, then, yeah,
that would be pretty awful.
Right?
But seeing as you were both
eight at the time of the dream,
I think it's perfectly
natural to have
those sorts of tendencies.
I don't think that you
need to be ashamed at all.
And, in fact, in
fact, Ben, I think
it's very brave that
you admitted it.
BEN: Dude, how do
you always know what
to say to make me feel better.
KALYAN: I also have another
thought that I think
might make you feel better.
BEN: Another thought that
might make me feel better?
Sorry, I fucking love you.
Go ahead.
Sorry.
KALYAN: OK, I think it's very
responsible the way you laid
out newspaper in your dream.
I think it says a lot
more about your character
that you laid down
newspaper to protect
the floor of the classroom and
to catch the fecal matter that,
I take, had missed your face.
Then, it does a part
your sexual deviances.
In fact, I don't think that
you need to be embarrassed
about that dream, at all.
I think it shows a great
character and an ability
to love another person despite
their off-putting bodily
functions.
The fact that she's
doing that on your face
and you still love her--
BEN: Yeah.
KALYAN: --is so sweet.
Makes me feel like you're going
to make some other woman really
happy someday.
BEN: Who the fuck are you?
You are the most perfect
person that ever exists.
I've been haunted by
this for 20 years.
KALYAN: Listen to me though Ben.
Having said all of this, I
do have one piece of advice
that you can either choose
to heed or not to heed.
BEN: Yes, of course,
please advise.
Of course, I'll heed, you
perfect fucking specimen
of a friend.
KALYAN: If you asked to make a
speech at the upcoming wedding,
I would leave this story out.
BEN: You are the
best fucking roommate
I have ever had in my life.
Do you know that?
Dude, you really fucking are.
And you know what,
oh my god, you
know what, I would actually
love that Wall Street douche bag
to meet you.
Oh, I would fucking love that.
My crazy Nepalese roommate.
Yo, let's get that fuck
over here for some drinks.
KALYAN: Thank you.
BEN: Thanks so much.
KALYAN: Suck it.
INTERVIEWER: I'm so sorry.
I forgot the [INAUDIBLE].
That's why you should let
real professional actors do
the heavy lifting.
JESSE: Oh, right, yeah.
KUNAL: Oh, no, no.
It's funny talking about it then
suddenly getting into and doing
it.
JESSE: Yeah, yeah.
KUNAL: Right?
JESSE: Yeah, strange.
INTERVIEWER: So I had a
chance to see the show--
JESSE: Oh, great.
INTERVIEWER: --last weekend.
And it was a reception similar
to this, people got it,
they were into it.
And, just overall, it was
just a great experience
at the theater-- acting,
directing, writing.
And that set is awesome.
JESSE: Oh, thanks.
KUNAL: Oh, thanks.
INTERVIEWER: So you're
here and thank you
for coming to Google
this afternoon.
And we'll sort of alternate with
some questions for a little bit
then ask the gang
if they would like
to step up and ask a couple.
So I'll start from
my left, Jesse,
you're someone now--
you've actually
got a pretty continuous
career as a playwright.
This is your third off-Broadway
production, here in New York.
And you act and you write.
And so, for you,
when did you start
feeling like you wanted
to write down the stuff
that you wanted to act?
And how you did you get
into that as a craft.
JESSE: I have been
writing for a long time,
but never with the
intention of acting
in the plays or the other
things that I've written,
that were not plays.
But I, including
this one, in fact,
I tried to find other actors
to do the part before I did it,
because I just feel a lot
of anxiety doing the show's.
Not because I don't
like performing them,
but I just feel so-- I've just
like the general stage fright
that people have.
So I try to avoid
acting in them.
But, then it gets
into a point where
I feel like I'm the only
person who could do it,
because it's in my mind.
And now that I'm
doing the play with,
this is actually a-- this
play has a cast of five,
Kunal is the other
main character with me.
And now I can't picture
anybody else but him doing it.
So now you end up boxing
yourself in psychologically.
But, I will say,
though an answer
more specifically
to your question,
partly a lot of the characters
that I write probably
stem from real things or
maybe even frustrations
I have as an actor.
Like if I'm playing
in a certain role,
and I don't like the role for
whatever set of reasons that I
feel comfortable by, maybe
I'll write the opposite
or the inverse role for a play.
INTERVIEWER: OK,
that's great to know.
And then when you
actually do let it go
and other companies
pick it up, you'll
have a chance to see how other
people interpret your work.
JESSE: Yeah, I saw my last
play-- I saw it in actually--
it was in Israel-- it's
still playing there.
I saw it in Hebrew.
And it was wonderful.
Partly there because of
the language barrier,
I wasn't so critical of
it because I couldn't
hear what they were saying.
But it was a nice experience.
INTERVIEWER: And then
now with Kunal, you've
done a lot of stage
work, actually.
Has it been a while for you
since you've been on stage?
And have you been
in New York before?
KUNAL: The last play I did
was in 2007, in Los Angeles.
But we shoot Big Bang in
front of live audience,
so that's every Tuesday night.
So it's not like
I was never having
been on stage since 2007, I'm
on stage every Tuesday night.
But it's obviously a
different atmosphere.
But, yeah, I mean, being on
that show for eight years
has really prepped me.
I thought it would
be the opposite.
I thought I've
been stuck playing
this one character
for eight years,
will I remember how to do this?
But I think I was
silly in not realizing
that I've learned a lot
over the last eight years.
INTERVIEWER: So your
acting muscles were already
in pretty good shape?
KUNAL: Yeah, yeah.
And not that I've been--
yeah, there was a joke,
and I lost it.
Thinking about heavy
lifting and-- what was it?
I'm not doing anything or some--
JESSE: Go through the
details of the joke.
They're funniest.
KUNAL: Jesse writes
my jokes for me.
So, I haven't had time
this morning to prep.
JESSE: Right.
INTERVIEWER: And you guys
have such an amazing chemistry
onstage.
What's it been like for you
developing the relationship
with each other and working?
And what sort of things
do you do for each other
on stage that make it
all the more fun to do?
JESSE: I think there's
like a few things happening
on stage between actors
in plays that don't happen
in the same way in movies.
Which is that, I think
there's this almost telepathic
relationship that's occurring
underneath the surface
of the dialogue in the behavior,
which is-- we are so in tune
with each other, by virtue of
having done it so many times
and knowing what each other are
trying to accomplish onstage
and what we're trying to
accomplish as a group,
that there's almost this tacit
dialogue that's occurring
simultaneously with the play.
We know that tonight will be
our 40th show or something,
and we've rehearsed
for two months.
So we have a sense
of the minute pauses,
I mean, half-second pauses that
we know affect the other guy,
and the other guy doesn't
like that half-second pause.
And that's not something we've
ever articulated explicitly,
but we know that that's
what the other guy's go--
that's what's going
on in his mind,
that you end up creating this
really incredible unspoken
dialogue.
And it's really special.
KUNAL: And every
night is different.
That's the thing.
You have no idea
what the audience
is going to bring
on any given night--
where they're going to laugh,
what they're going to say.
If someone coughs
over a line, you
have to repeat that information
to set up for another joke.
So you have to be so incredibly
in tune with each other.
Sometimes you drop a
line or sometimes you
get caught up in
the moment, and you
do something that is
out of the ordinary
that you're not used to
and the person on stage,
you have to trust that
they're going to pick it up.
Sometimes maybe you're
not feeling it, maybe
not in the moment, and then your
partner just grabs your face
and looks you in the eye and
then you're back in to it.
There's so much going on
stage and anything can change.
In any given moment,
anything can change.
And that's the beauty
of being blessed
enough to work with
a talented actor
like Jesse is that you
have complete trust.
Anything can happen.
No matter what happens you have
complete trust that you're not
going to be left hanging.
INTERVIEWER: Yeah, that's also
the beauty of live theater.
And so, as you've gone
from words on a page
to working with each
other and a director
now on stage, what are some
of the things that both of you
have learned or insights
you've had about either
the play itself or about
yourself as an actor,
either one of you?
KUNAL: Go ahead.
JESSE: I feel like acting is
a bit like playing the drums.
It's hard to do it on your own.
And I do feel like the
more practice you get
at it, the better you become.
That sounds like
an obvious thing.
But it's-- unfortunately, it's
not-- acting, as a profession,
is not really
thought of that way.
Because you don't necessarily
have to have a degree.
You don't necessarily have
to have specific training.
A lot of times the
most famous people
that you see in the profession
of acting have never,
are not really good at it.
Just by virtue of them
being very attractive
or whatever-- it's just the
nature of the profession.
That's not something
that we deal with.
So, it's an unusual
profession, in that regard.
And I think getting to
do a play every night
and rehearsing for
it, you just end up
getting better at your job
by virtue of doing it a lot.
I guess it's like
the Malcolm Gladwell
philosophy in that way.
And so, I think we're
getting better in the play.
But I think probably even
more importantly we're
probably getting
better at our job,
just by virtue of doing it.
INTERVIEWER: That's
always great to hear.
And it's also, because
you're putting something
into something that you
love you get stuff back,
which is a really cool.
JESSE: That's right.
INTERVIEWER: So yes.
And you have an MFA,
actually, so you've done
some serious acting training.
So what are the sort
of things that you'd
like to continue to
work on and accomplish
and what are the things
that you feel like you
bring to a role like this?
KUNAL: I think its-- grad
school really taught me
how to prepare.
I think that's something that
you don't-- it's hard sometimes
to realize how to break
down a script and prepare.
Oftentimes, actors will just
show up to the first rehearsal
without having thought
about it a lot.
And that's fine, and then
they'll still be incredible.
But, for me, I really
have to take the time
to be meticulous about
every single beat
and try to think
about everything.
And try to create every moment,
so that when I do rehearse
I'm not thinking about
what I have to say next.
I'm just saying
it in the moment.
And I think that's what grad
school really taught me is,
if you don't know your lines
or if you feel ill-prepared
then you're doing the
work in rehearsal.
You're not really
doing the work.
You're working on it by
yourself in rehearsal
as opposed to just
being present and being
there for you're partners or
being there for the director.
And I think that's what going
through a rigorous program
really teaches you
is how to prepare.
INTERVIEWER: And I think
that's really important too.
So and you've both
now-- you do work a lot.
You're committed to your
craft, which is a great thing.
And you add to, I guess,
your quiver full of talents
as you move on to
the next thing.
So, this show has
been wonderful.
What sort of things are you
thinking about doing next,
for both of you?
KUNAL: I have to go back
to Season 9 in August.
So, I don't have much
opportunity to think about.
I have a book coming out
September 15th about my journey
from New Delhi to Los Angeles
called, Yes, My Accent is Real.
And I'm competing,
unfortunately,
against Jesse's book that comes
out on September 15th, as well.
What is that called?
JESSE: It's called,
my accent's fake.
INTERVIEWER: So tell
us both about the book.
Because when you have
something-- obviously
people here are going to want
to read the book-- so, tell us
the real title, and the
publisher, and about
when it's coming out.
JESSE: Do you want to finish--
KUNAL: Oh, yeah, my book,
Yes, My Accent is Real,
it's about my journey from Delhi
to LA, and growing up in India,
and a lot of fun stuff.
And it's Atria,
Simon & Schuster.
It's out September 15th.
INTERVIEWER: OK.
JESSE: My book is,
actually, it's called,
Bream Gives Me Hiccups.
It's a collection
of short stories.
Some have been published in
the New Yorker, McSweeney's,
in the Shouts and Murmurs
section of New Yorker.
And it's coming out, Grove
Atlantic, in September.
And yeah, it's like short humor.
INTERVIEWER: Yeah, I love
the essays in The New Yorker.
JESSE: Oh, thanks.
INTERVIEWER: Those are fun.
They're actually-- it's in some
ways, you're, in many ways,
like a classic New York writer.
Because you act, you write, you
have stuff in The New Yorker,
you show up and you
do interesting things.
Is that something-- I
guess, it is something
that clearly feeds you.
JESSE: Yeah, I like it.
I haven't set out to copy
that particular path, which
I think we can read as Jewish.
But I like all those things.
Yeah, there's probably some,
let's say, cultural glue that
binds those things together.
But, I like them for
separate reasons.
So the next thing I'm
doing, in a month,
I start Woody
Allen's next movie.
And so, I guess they're--
so it seems almost like
as an outsider, in retrospect--
like obviously all linked
to each other.
But I like doing these
things for different reasons.
And I feel like when we're
onstage, it feels more like,
I don't know, it feels like
we're like in a wrestling match
onstage, or something,
it's this very
visceral, emotional,
cathartic experience on stage.
Like what you just saw is
the beginning of the play,
but the play becomes
a very dark play.
As you can see in
the opening, there's
some elements underneath
lurking that feel dangerous.
It doesn't feel
like I'm performing
a light, witty thing.
It feels like this
very visceral thing.
So I don't see the
connection as much
between writing humor
for The New Yorker
and performing this
thing, which feels
like a UFC fight or something.
Doesn't it?
KUNAL: Yeah, it's exhausting.
It is.
I hope you guys
come see the play.
It's rare to find an actor who
can write as well as Jesse.
And so while it's on, I think
it's a great opportunity
to see the future of the
Jewish industry that--
JESSE: I tell you, we're
about to take over--
not just entertainment, but some
parts of law and Wall Street.
INTERVIEWER: Well, it
is such a good show.
And it makes me happy,
as a theater goer,
to see a piece that's
overall that strong,
which makes-- it's
just sometimes
when you go to the
theater, you go, oh,
we're just not going to look
at that actor that much.
Or, oh man, I wish the
door hadn't fallen off,
and stuff like.
JESSE: Our doors stay on.
KUNAL: Our doors-- yeah.
INTERVIEWER: There you go.
KUNAL: It's come-- it's not
been hinged fully sometimes.
It's come apart.
INTERVIEWER: So you had
some issues with the broom
last week.
JESSE: Oh, you
were at that show?
KUNAL: You were at that show?
JESSE: Oh, god.
Fucking-- that was
one performance--
KUNAL: Literally, the
one before the broom,
it just kept falling out.
I just-- I took it off stage
and I threw in backstage.
I was like--
INTERVIEWER: But
you dealt with it.
You dealt with it in
the moment as you would.
You just picked it up and said,
oh, it's not staying there--
KUNAL: I was just Kunal,
being like, fuck it.
JESSE: Yeah.
I think Olivia did the
same thing, didn't it?
KUNAL: Yeah.
Just me and Olivia.
INTERVIEWER: So if
you want, people
can start heading up
to the microphones.
We have--
KUNAL: Yes, ask questions.
INTERVIEWER: --one
on either side.
KUNAL: Please, ask us anything.
INTERVIEWER: And know
we have some folks here
who are huge fans
of the both of you.
And you get to head back to this
really, really funny show very
soon and that people here,
as I'm sure you can imagine,
they quote it religiously,
and often wear the t-shirts.
KUNAL: Oh, yeah.
INTERVIEWER: Yes.
KUNAL: Not creepy at all.
INTERVIEWER: So, if anybody--
JESSE: Yeah, exactly.
KUNAL: No, I'm joking.
INTERVIEWER:
--would like to make
their way to the microphone.
We can have a couple minutes
of cha-- look there's, good,
there's people actually--
KUNAL: Yeah, yeah, ask
don't be shy, please.
Shout it out if you
don't use the mike.
I mean--
AUDIENCE: Hi, there, yeah.
So, I'm just-- this is
for both of you guys.
I'm wondering is there any
sort of connecting thread
that you guys have noticed
between the types of characters
that you most
enjoy playing, when
you get those sorts of roles?
KUNAL: You want to?
JESSE: I mean, I like-- I
usu-- I mean the characters
I've written for--this is my
third play to be done in New
York and the
characters, I guess,
are all considered
despicable people.
But I-- that seems to me the
most interesting thing to play.
Because then the
job is to humanize
these people that are otherwise
doing horrible things.
I mean, the play, the
guy becomes really
off the rails towards the end of
the play, of what we just did.
And yeah, to me,
that's exhilarating.
Because then my job is to
humanize them in the same way
that if somebody is a
terrible person in real life,
if you ask them, they'll
defend themselves
and they'll have some kind of
emotional reason for doing--
for behaving that way.
KUNAL: Yeah, I mean, I tend
to, oftentimes, get cast
as the sweet,
innocent, naive guy.
INTERVIEWER: Huh.
JESSE: But, in this play--
KUNAL: But in this play--
JESSE: Talk about it.
KUNAL: Exactly, but in
this play this character
is very, when you see the
whole play you'll realize
that this character's grounded.
He's a very much a grounded
guy, which is rare for me.
And I'm lucky to have an
opportunity to actually play
someone would some gravitas.
JESSE: In all the ways
he pacifiers my character
in this first
scene, which he does
in a kind of submissive way,
all kind of come around.
He kind of grows up in the play.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: You
got anybody else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Over the
course of your acting,
both your acting careers, you've
met really incredible people.
And I'm so admire
both your works.
I love Big Bang
Theory and I watch
a lot of your movies, Jesse.
And so I was wondering
what celebrities
that you've met, that you
just really admire, as well.
And what was the funniest
interaction with any celebrity?
KUNAL: I met Jesse Eisenberg
about two months ago.
Yeah, that was funny?
JESSE: It was really funny.
Tell them what happened.
Tell them exactly what happened.
KUNAL: So, Jesse--
JESSE: No, nothing happened.
KUNAL: Like, is there
a story there I forgot?
JESSE: No, no, no.
KUNAL: I remember meeting
Stephen Hawking when
he was going to be on Big Bang.
He came to set to
watch a run-through.
And, obviously, it's quite a
sight to spend time with him.
Obviously, it can be
just-- of his state
and also of who he is.
And so, it was just amazing
being in its presence.
And he watched the run-through
and in the run-through
Simon Helberg is actually
making fun of Stephen Hawking
and doing his voice.
JESSE: Oh, really.
KUNAL: Yeah.
And I'm like-- and we're
doing this run-through,
and I just looked
at Stephen Hawking.
And Stephen Hawking was smiling.
And he loved it.
But he loved it.
But he went home and
read the script again.
And now he's come on our show
like three or four times.
So it's really cool to meet him.
We got to meet
Leonard Nimoy, too.
All the people that
you would imagine
would be on The Big Bang
Theory, that was fun.
What about you?
Tell them about when
you met George Clooney.
JESSE: Oh, my god, George.
(FANATIC VOICE) I'm
rarely tongue-tied
tied but, no-- (NORMAL VOICE)
Well, it's interesting to see,
for me to see the
people who seem
to be at the kind of
most accomplished point
in their lives, or careers, or
artistic achievements who are
still really worried about it.
So the last play I did the main
actress was Vanessa Redgrave.
She's like 76 years old,
77 years old, at the time.
And she was in the
theater like every day
4 o'clock for an 8 o'clock
show, pouring over her script.
OK?
No, but it's just
amazing you think,
here this woman doesn't-- this
woman is finished accomplishing
anything that anybody
could accomplish something,
not because of her age, just
because of her achievements.
And she still really
worried about the play.
We did, let's say, 90 shows
or something, the 89th show,
she's sitting
backstage panicked.
And that's, to me, is like
the most impressive thing,
that somebody is still worried
about it, which tells me, A)
it's OK to worry about
doing a good job.
That doesn't mean
you're not going
to do a good job probably means
you're going to a better job.
And B) that there's no
point that you reach
that you can become complacent.
And I think that it transcends
industry, and talent,
and achievement.
That's I think the life
lesson that I took from that.
KUNAL: We're always scared
we're never going to work again.
I mean, seriously.
Its' weird being an
actor, because you never
know where your next paycheck
is going to come from.
But you know what I mean.
AUDIENCE: On Big Bang
Theory, you're kind of--
KUNAL: But you know what I mean.
JESSE: Yeah, yeah but
more than just fears
of industrial collapse,
more the fears of just,
I want to do good for myself
even if it's for 17 people are
in the audience tonight.
You want to do
good for yourself.
If no one's in the audience, you
want to do good for yourself.
And that's, I think
probably the biggest thing.
And then all this other stuff
like the money, or success,
or whatever that probably
will follow if you're doing
all those other things well.
AUDIENCE: What's the
funniest gaff that you've
done, either on a movie set,
or during a play, or anything.
JESSE: We don't do that.
INTERVIEWER: KUNAL: Yeah, we're
very serious about everything.
JESSE: Every single
night perfect.
Yeah.
One time I thought we'd
screw up, but then that--
INTERVIEWER: Thanks so much.
JESSE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: It's always
incredible to see
you working artists and then
diversified working artists,
like you both write.
You're doing a serial,
you're in all these movies
simultaneously.
I guess the one
thing that always
baffles me is how do
you deal with burnout?
Like what is your
schedule, and how
do you even start to
fight potential burnout?
And how do you keep
everything aligned
so that you can stay
focused moving from task,
to task, to task that you
either are recruited for
or you just kind of
creating yourselves.
JESSE: We get 20% of
our week time off.
Google joke.
What they get here.
KUNAL: Really?
JESSE: They all get 20%, yeah.
They--
KUNAL: They get, what?
20% what?
JESSE: 20% of their jobs,
they get to work on--
KUNAL: You guys hiring?
Burnout.
JESSE: Burnout is like-- the
luckiest actor in the world
gets burnout.
Because typically you're not
working as much as it seems.
We're in a very public thing.
So I pass the subway every day
and there's pictures of Kunal
for his show.
But I know he has nothing to do
with it for these three months.
And similarly, I'm in a poster
that's coming out, or whatever.
But I did that movie
a year and a half ago.
So I think the
nature of our jobs
makes it look like we are
probably working more than--
KUNAL: Yes.
JESSE: --than we actually are.
KUNAL: We have downtime
in between our projects.
But there are times
when you feel exhausted.
And then you sleep and you
wake up the next morning
and you're fine.
Like all of us, seriously,
what are you going to do?
What are you going to
do with your ambition?
What's burnout?
Seriously?
What are you going to-- what
do you do with your ambition?
You can't do anything with it,
you have to just keep reaching.
And so I don't-- burnout is
not a word in my vocabulary.
No, but seri-- I don't
know why I said that.
JESSE: It's just because
you don't know the word.
KUNAL: Yeah.
It's because I don't actually
understand English that well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you guys.
JESSE: Thank you very much.
INTERVIEWER: And we
have one more over here.
AUDIENCE: All right, so
thanks for coming, guys.
This question is more for Jesse.
And it's sort of
off topic, so feel
free to punt on it if you want.
But given your involvement
in The Social Network,
and given the fact that
you're here, and also given--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I guess, yeah, that's
kind of what I'm getting at.
Is there's a bit of
a common theme there.
Right?
But also looking at
some of the opinions
that were apparent in the
opening scene on the banking
industry or whatever.
Do you have any specific
opinions on how Google sits,
right now?
JESSE: Oh, right, right.
AUDIENCE: In the world could
there be a play in the future
that involves maybe
some of these walls--
JESSE: Right, no, no,
honestly, not at all.
No, I mean, I know
really nothing
about any of those industries.
My character, though,
also knows nothing.
He is a guy who
demonizes banking
because he's jealous of
anybody having a job.
And he runs into this
guy in the street who's
marrying this girl he likes.
So that's where that comes from.
I know nothing about
those industries.
Acting in a movie, playing a
guy who knows about computers,
is really just that.
It's the same as
probably the actors
who were in Jurassic
Park knowing
about Tyrannosaurus Rex's and--
AUDIENCE: That's
a good comparison.
JESSE: They probably
very little.
KUNAL: Or playing
an astrophysicist
who knows shit about anything.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
JESSE: But I don't know you
guys seem like the smartest
people on earth work here.
So, I'm sure you guys
will do good things.
And be-- I mean, I don't know,
I mean, so my opinion of Google
is that seems like it's being
populated by the greatest
minds in the world.
So, I guess, that's wonderful.
I don't know on the corporate
side, what they're doing,
maybe it's horrible.
INTERVIEWER: OK.
So we'll go along with
that, that the greatest
minds work here.
OK, so we have one here,
and then one last question
to wrap it up.
AUDIENCE: This is, I guess,
especially for Jesse.
You seem pretty into your craft.
Where would you like to see
yourself in 20 years, to say,
I've had a good career or
what would make you happy?
What are you aiming for?
JESSE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It seems like
that's something you'd--
JESSE: I just, I
want to do it more.
I can't-- this play that we're
doing now is just like came
from like a flurry of like
thoughts and bad the emotions
and stuff like that.
And so like I don't have
any kind of real discipline.
That's what I would like.
I write a lot.
But I don't have the discipline.
I want to be able to A)
develop some discipline and B)
be able to maintain it.
And I don't have that now.
I've been very prolific.
I'm also-- I have
the great advantage
of being a known actor, so
people will publish my books
and plays.
They're probably on par
with the other things that
are being published,
but they probably
get to the top of the pile
a little more quickly.
So I'd like to be able
to continue working
and that's my goal.
AUDIENCE: So I have two.
If you have time for
only one, that's fine.
So, 1) taking a step back, I'm
curious when, in your lives
or at what age was like a
turning point or an aha moment
where you realized you
wanted to be an actor
or realized you were
different from everyone else.
And you wanted to pursue that.
Was there a mentor?
How did that develop?
And then curious
about the future,
also, so being at
Google and thinking
about the future of media
consumption, and theater,
and entertainment, YouTube, and
in person, online digital era,
where do you see the
future of your careers
acting careers, entertainment
TV careers, movies.
What do you think about that?
JESSE: Well, I think about the
second question all the time.
KUNAL: Yeah, me too.
JESSE: I do feel like I'm
in a very, very fortunate
but ultimately
unsustainable place.
As an actor who is able
to make money and be
successful in the way I am.
I really feel like
it's unsustainable,
because it seems like
entertainment is becoming
diversified in such a way that
being in the big movie that
comes out that
weekend or whatever
seems to be-- it's
still holding on,
but it seems to be like
the past, in my opinion.
KUNAL: But at the same time, if
you were to do an independent,
like a small
independent movie that
also could have more legs
because of the digital age.
Correct?
JESSE: Yes, possibly
but it's big.
There are so many--
just by virtue
of that being cheaper
to make-- there
will be a lot more of those
competing with each other.
Right now, we're
doing this play,
we're both very successful
actors like in financial--
AUDIENCE: And very modest.
JESSE: What's that?
No, no, no, but I have to
preface it by saying that,
so this is not a complaint.
But we make like
$400 a week doing
this play, which is the most
exhausting thing that we
do in our careers.
So there's no correlation really
between like effort and money--
KUNAL: Money.
JESSE: --like in our
business, it seems.
The thing that I make the
most money from usually
are the easier things,
where you're on a set,
and you get a nice
trailer, everything.
AUDIENCE: That's
really interesting.
JESSE: So I don't
see the future of my
what I'm actually very
interested in being
economically sustainable.
And that might have
more to do with what
I'm interested in, which
is of these smaller things
than what the
industry's going to do.
Do you have an opinion about it?
KUNAL: Yeah, no, I agree.
Doing theater is exhausting.
But you get nothing
to do it, but it's
fulfilling as an artist.
But it's exhausting.
And I just think
everything's going digital.
Everything is.
And as much as you
want to be, hey, I
want to preserve these things.
But why do we want
to preserve anything?
If it's going to
digital, that's great.
It gives a lot more people
who have a lot more talent
to be discovered, as well.
JESSE: That's true.
Except I do think they will
be, like everything there's
pendulum shifts, so I
do think the backlash
to everybody looking
at the telephones
to get their entertainment
may be in theaters
favor in a few years time.
We'll all be rushing to where
we want to see real people.
There may be that backlash.
I hope so.
INTERVIEWER: I hope theater's
not going away anywhere.
And one of things
that you guys have.
And it is when you're being
pragmatic and assessing
yourself as successful it's
because you have the capacity
to do one thing that
another of one thing
allows you to do other.
JESSE: That's true.
INTERVIEWER: And also
that the more experience
you acquire and, frankly, the
more influence the more people
you can bring along after you.
JESSE: Absolutely.
INTERVIEWER: And that's
an important part
of being an artist.
JESSE: Yeah, that's true.
Thanks, Kathleen.
KUNAL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: OK.
Well, gang this
has been wonderful.
Thank you so much
for coming out.
KUNAL: Thanks guys
so much for coming.
INTERVIEWER: Thank
you, Jesse and Kunal.